you
you
my grasp futile
no hint of hope it's all mine
Oh
oh I'm just not there now
oh my hi
oh sure
but I fight
first my fight
or is it hard
and it's you
will I be relieved
from this prison I'll be turning
there's
to see me
Harold Shepard
me follow
where is she
tell me why I see the
what
the monarchy
me too
I will fight
and it's my food
for me it's never
this prison I'll be charting days it all
inside
to see me
lead me to the light though it will
leave me blah
and brain is truly
turning
it is not
I see
you
Oh
if you really enjoyed this song then
you'll get a lot out of listening for a
few more minutes because firstly we
wanted to make this song available to as
many of you as possible so it's
available in a pay what you want format
basically whatever you feel this song is
worth to you that's what it costs down
in the description is a link to the
artists Bandcamp page and I'd be so
thankful if you could go over there and
support the artists even just a little
bit for creating this piece because
Ashlyn has straight-up killed it with
this project she is professional she's
been enthusiastic she wants to learn
about the universe and what would make a
great soul song for you guys and if you
can just pass a little bit of that
thanks to her that would mean so much I
want to build this as something that's
really beneficial for artists to
contribute to because it's so difficult
to get noticed and grow an audience and
you are such a huge part of that
secondly this video was made with the
help of my 803 amazing patrons on
patreon com who helped pay for studio
higher instruments sound engineering and
services that produce this piece so I
have to say thank you here to those guys
if you're still feeling generous after
supporting Ashlyn and do you want to
become a patron of my channel then click
the bonfire to Kindle the channel by
doing this you get some small privileges
like seeing videos early and I just hope
I can repay you in some small way lastly
some of you might want to check out the
artists other work and you can do that
too below is a link to her YouTube page
where she has a bunch of other songs
that are similar to this one so go there
and just enjoy yourself listening to her
music because even a small act like that
really makes a difference if you're
interested in more soul song there is
another song that exists it's called
Lord vessel by tanooki suit so here's a
link to that and in the future I'm going
to have a lot more of this to give you
guys and I can't
to show you that as well because these
are some really fun projects to work on
and I wouldn't be able to do it without
you guys
so thank you and I'll see you in the
next one Cheers